conservatives are rightly skeptical of
the claim that regulation protects
consumers and promotes competition
frequently the opposite happens
in fact regulation can entrenched
bureaucracy and perpetuate large
companies but the situation with online
privacy is different the US has enjoyed
the world's greatest internet economy
because it had a single national policy
from the beginning indeed our
constitutional framers Madison and
Hamilton advocated for a single national
marketplace to protect against
contradictory state laws this policy has
worked well for the online economy a
person could set up a website and sell
anywhere in the USA but this is no
longer the case California just made its
own privacy law and other states are
following suit threatening to fracture
the US with 50 separate sets of privacy
rules once again the US needs to make
strong federal policy to replace the
current patchwork of conflicting laws
this will preserve our seamless internet
economy and ensure a common privacy
standard for all Americans what do you
think about online privacy legislation
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI